the process of writing and running sql
queries doesn't always follow a straight
line
a particular query can be in constant
iteration while you use it to explore
and clean up your data
or as you fine-tune it to optimize its
performance
in today's episode we highlight the ways
to save and share queries in bigquery
to help you navigate these bins in the
road
[Music]
so you ran a query last friday for your
colleague and sent them the results
all done right wrong it's monday morning
and now there's another request for
additional data fields on the same query
the new request requires you to join
data from another table
enjoying what you actually did in a
separate query a few weeks ago
but you can't quite remember how you did
it do you really want to write a new sql
query from scratch
no i mean it's great practice but it's
not always the most practical
luckily bigquery has features built in
that allow you to view your query
history
proactively save specific queries and
share queries with others
let's take a look at each of these
features a bit further
your first line of defense for
revisiting pass queries in bigquery is
your query history
this feature is automatic and includes
the text of all queries you have run
you can view your query history in the
console by selecting query history in
the top left-hand nav
click on a specific query and you'll see
the text of the query
and be able to open it in the editor so
you can modify and rerun it
just note this history is limited to 1
000 queries and looks back up to 6
months
going a step further you can decide to
proactively name and save a specific
query
just enter the query valid or not in the
editor
then click save query located just to
the right of the run button
give the query a name and then click
save
you can find a list of your saved
queries in the left-hand nav
similar to the functionality in your
query history you can now click to open
the query in the editor
modify it and run it if you want to
share one of your queries with a
colleague
you can create shared queries you can
create a shared query by first saving
a query turning on link sharing and then
sharing the unique url
a shared query provides the query text
only
so users that open your shared query
will still need to have appropriate
access to the tables referenced in the
query to be able to
run it for more information on how to
share access to data sets using identity
and access management or iam
watch our last episode managing access
with cloudiam
linked in the description below other
users will be restricted from editing
your personal saved queries if you're
looking to make saved queries editable
by your team members
you'll need to change the saved query
visibility to project
and then grant your team members the
permissions to get lists and
update saved queries in your project so
now that you have the text of the query
covered
what about the query results just as
bigquery automatically saves your query
history
it also by default caches the results of
your successfully run queries in
temporary tables
these tables expire after 24 hours and
within this time
you can browse the results through your
query history
just select the query and scroll to find
a link to the temporary table
here you can preview the data and also
export the full table to cloud storage
if you rerun the query bigquery will use
the cached results if it can
meaning if you are still within the 24
hour period and the underlying data has
not had any changes
by using cached results you won't incur
any query costs
temporary tables are available only to
the specific user that runs the query
so if you're looking to share the query
results you should consider saving them
to a permanent table
you can make the switch from saving in a
temporary table to a permanent table
by opening the query settings and
setting a destination table for the
results
click run and after the query is
complete you will see the new table in
the left-hand nav
you can then use iam to share the
destination data set or table with your
collaborators
it's important to note permanent tables
will incur storage costs while temporary
tables do not
another method for sharing results is to
use the option to save them
immediately after running your query
click the save results button and choose
between several options for saving
results
locally in google drive or directly to a
google sheet
we've now reviewed how to save and share
query text and query results
but there's one more tool to cover which
is called views
a view is a virtual table defined by a
query
a view can be queried just like you
query a table views are listed next to
tables in a data set denoted with a
different icon
when running a query that references a
view bigquery will also run the query
that defines that view
so why would views be helpful views can
help hide the complexity
of data by allowing you to join multiple
tables into a single virtual table
ready to query views can be a good
alternative to sharing query text
because then you can take advantage of
the finer green controls available in
cloudiam to share the view and the
underlying tables
views do not require storage since
they're virtual tables there's not a
storage cost associated with them
to create a view write the query that
defines the view in the query editor
and then click save view choose the
project and data set where you'd like
the view to live and then give the view
a name
click save the view will populate under
the destination data set and can be
queried just like you query a table
now that you know how to save and share
queries it's time for you to try
if you haven't created your bigquery
sandbox do so by following the link
below
once you're in the console click add
data explore public data sets
and then pick out your favorite one
write a query and share it with a friend
and in the comments below if you like if
you want to learn more about bigquery
check out the rest of our playlist and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
on youtube for other great content
look out for our next episode of
bigquery spotlight and remember
stay curious
[Music]